a blitz service Tommy caffee what  happened um hello tsunami for fun or for  your mommy fell down the stairs in my  fashion so let's go baby  what's your name homework and the whole  Vienna  oh you're three or I am a my name's  Sarah we're gonna help your mommy okay  mommy's breathing is she all right -  Adomian acted that they say on the side  I'm not gonna have to kind of hey  remember me tongue roll the babies in  mommy's tummy  okay CJ or am i selling ads okay good  girl Emma your super saw your mummy  she'll be really proud of you what's  mommy doing now no more hopeful you're  giving money a puzzle first girl you're  lucky I was gonna bring you a baby  brother okay that's offering it mommy's  gonna bring a she  you